come with me if you want to live it's
okay mom shoot hell 25 years ago this
weekend Arnold Schwarzenegger made good
on his promise I'll be back he actually
came back in Terminator 2 the film went
on to be the biggest hit in the entire
franchise and it grossed more than half
a billion dollars and here's the really
cool thing we were along with Arnold for
that wild ride so in honor of flashback
Friday we're taking you back to the set
of Terminator 2 PT and terminator is in
common to the Olympus alphabet GT is and
reports accurately we love the props
Arnold but what we really noticed on set
was how his face lit up every time he
talked T - of course I'm jazzed about t2
because I know it's going to be the huge
big blockbuster of the summer and it is
exciting come with me if you want to
live exciting and a lot of fun for us to
cover art was red carpet royalty at the
movies 1991 premiere he arrived with
wife Maria Shriver and they had a
surprise to share right now we are
looking forward to our second baby right
so that's what we're really looking
forward at the time sports and Egger was
promoting the most expensive film ever
made with a budget of 102 million
dollars we are very happy that it could
spend the money because it's all on the
screen so you know people pay $7 but
they get they get $30 worth of movie now
speaking of money this is interesting
Schwarzenegger was paid $21,000 per word
hasta LaVista
baby that's considering he only speaks
700 words in the film divide that by his
15 million dollar salary another stand
out Linda Hamilton as Sarah Connor there
are a lot of life lessons that I learned
yeah even with a training not just the
military training but just a you know
you keep going and your muscles hurt you
just push through it and there's such a
satisfaction in serenity it comes from
you next whatever happened to Edward
Furlong who played her son it was really
fun
poised for stardom he was only 13 when
we sat down with him I had to do a lot
of exercising and work with him guns a
lot like many young stars for long
battle drugs and alcohol and his career
faltered in 2013 he was arrested for
allegedly assaulting his ex-girlfriend
back on set we also got an early look at
director James Cameron in action six
years before he made Titanic everybody
off the second
say they got you I go for perfection but
there is no such thing as perfection
this perfection is subjective I just
want it to be the best that it can be
the hard work paid off
that in Arnold's superhuman enthusiasm I
enjoy doing great films
I enjoy promoting the film South Korea
and I'm happy with my life